hi i'm norman reedus and this is my test
angeles okay my first thing on my
essentialist it's probably my francis
francis espresso maker i like to drink
my coffee in my Sean Patrick Flanery
coffee cup which says zombies are
looking for brains don't worry you're
safe okay the next one on the list is
this kills original musk stuff I hug a
lot of people I'm kind of a hugger so
I'm constantly shoving women's faces in
my neck so I try to save them by putting
this junk on another thing on my list is
I have one of these little robot gizmos
my cat likes it my kid actually talked
me into getting it and I just thought I
was going to just be a toy and then I
saw what a good job it does so now I
just I plug it in at night and I turn it
on in the morning and I plug it in at
night and surround the morning and it
just cleans my home floor all right next
to my list is this Fuji x20 camera that
I just got a fair man who plays guitar
when I was trying to pick out a guitar
to get he said get the one that you want
to hold the most because you play with
it the most which is I think it's the
same sort of thing about a camera I had
a friend Max Perla he used to travel
with one of these little record players
and he had all these 45s azolla Cuban
jazz records I sort of started
collecting old you know
punk rock 45s a lot of them are really
cool you know like this one's really
cool mean this is you know the teen
idols but it has like Ian MacKaye on
bass you got the Melvin's you got my
lesbian friends I like the artwork on
them and I like to just collect them and
play with them boom another one of my
favorite things on my list is a South
Park people ask me all the time they you
know what would you do in the clinic you
know the zombie apocalypse really
happened you know you like Daryl and I
see nothing like Daryl I'd probably go
to a hotel and lock myself in the top
top place and watch out for collectors
my life into this little blue pillow
right here is awesome because you can
you can take it on the plane you know I
mean people like to comment on my boobs
my next thing on the list are these ray
bands pretty much where these ray bands
everywhere I go and people say it's
obnoxious but it's nice to hide behind
sunglasses sometimes another thing on my
essentials list the triumph scrambler
sometimes I'll jump on the bike I won't
clean myself up after work because I'm
just too tired and I go home and I'll be
covered in blood
riding the bike home which gets a lot of
weird looks another thing on my list are
these slippers I carry these with me all
the time because everybody needs bunny
you
you